yeah so
so welcome to the simons institute and
and welcome to this
uh workshop on 50 years of
satisfiability the centrality of sat
in the theory of computing um uh i
this is going to be running throughout
the the semester on on most thursdays
um and i just wanted to say a big big
thank you to all the organizers for
for putting this workshop together
albert at sirius sambas paul beam
mati uh yavi salo
tony potassiu and neil thaipan so thanks
thanks for all your work in in putting
this together and uh
sam over to you okay thank you um
so yeah welcome to the first uh uh
workshop on 50 years of satisfiability
um
this is actually going to be a blend of
talks some are going to be historical
or reflective talks and others will be
uh talks on recent research so um
we're going to have a sort of a mix of
talks so i think it should be a good a
good
a good semester or term um as moshe
remarked
earlier this week we've changed the
workshop so we no longer have a workshop
occupying one week instead of workshop
occupies one morning of each week
or approximately a total of 13 weeks i
guess of meetings
so uh just an experiment a new way to
run workshops
so for our first speaker is jack edmonds
it's a great pleasure to have him here
jack was a pioneer in the study of
algorithms and
and polynomial time in particular his
famous 1965 papers on paths
trees and flowers stated what is now
called the column at edmonds thesis
that polynomial time should correspond
to feasible computation
um he's also credited with the
conjecture that
np intersect co-np equals p in the
mid-60s even before the formal
definitions of these classes
um he uh he
got his phd from the from the university
of maryland he worked at the national
bureau of standards which is now
nist for about 10 years he subsequently
was at the unit at the university of
waterloo
for many years uh he's well known for
his work on matching algorithms metroid
algorithms and a lot of other things as
well
and uh he had the von neumann theory
prize from informs i think it was 1985.
he tells me this is his first zoom talk
so
welcome he's going to present his talk
as a
as a pre-recorded video so i'll be
playing that for him
but you can ask questions i would
suggest
during the video itself to post
questions to the chat or the q a
window you can't interrupt them just
because the video is playing
and it's possible that i will take
uh interrupt the video while it's
playing and get questions from jack but
most likely i'll let them queue up and
let you ask questions at the end
but we'll just see how that plays out um
so
without further ado jack is gonna
jack do you want to say anything before
i start your video
[Laughter]
thanks for the intro okay all right very
good let me see
here i'm happy to be here
yeah we're very pleased to have you here
so let me see if i can make the share
screen work again
if necessary sam i can actually recite
it again
okay um well anytime you want me to stop
it just speak up
so i'm ready to start playing it though
so ah
started playing let let the recording do
it
time to begin yeah that's not very clear
for me
hello thank you for having me
helen hoffman died on january 18th
at 96 years old
he was a main founding father of
combinatorial optimization and other
mathematics
he was the first programmer of the
simplex method for linear programming
and the discoverer of its cycling
at the bureau of standards on one of the
first
[Music]
computers
in 1959
i got a job
at the national bureau standards
mathematics division
where i was assigned to the operations
research section
newly formed by
alan goldman who was effectively
hired by alan hoffman
so these two allens are
very important to my
involvement in algorithms
i was encouraged to study whatever might
be useful
the marriage theorem on systems of
distinct representatives blew my mind
prompting me to think about
np intersect cohen p
and the conjecture that it implies
p
this worked well enough that alan
goldman had his
mentor professor tucker at princeton
arranged for me to be a junior
participant
in a 1961 workshop at the rand
corporation
for everyone prominent in combinatorics
i had a eureka moment the day before i
was to preach to these high priests and
with the support of alan hoffman after
my talk
and with the support of alan
after my talk and so
np intersect cohen p took over
my life
np co-np theorems are sometimes called
good characterizations
marriage theorem is a good
characterization of when
a finite set of girls can be matched
to distinct boys they love
it provides a way for the matchmaker to
prove easily to the parents
whenever a desirable matching is not
possible
by showing them a subset of the girls
who together
love fewer boys than the
they are a
matching of all the girls to distinct
voice
they love is easy for the parents to
recognize
a subset of the girls which does not
love enough boys is also
easy for them to recognize
proving that one or the other always
exists
can be proved by a polynomial time
algorithm which always finds one or the
other
i was i was mystified
at first
by the paper of elmo and bong
say that the girls can be matched
to distinct boys they love
even only if every subset of girls
loves at least that many boys
is checking every subset of girls easier
than checking every possible matching
an implementation of their proof is
exponential
amazingly that proof is in a book
called god's proofs
when matthew's proof something exists
they like to think that
it is hard to find
algorithmically exponential proofs look
more elegant
to them
a predicate p of x a predicate means a
function
whose output is uh true or
false a predicate p of
x is called np
when it takes this form
there exists a y such that
f of x y is true
where the bit size of y is at most some
polynomial of the bit
size of x and where
f of x y is a predicate given by a known
polynomial time algorithm that is
whose running time is bounded by
some polynomial in the bit sizes of
x and y
well you probably
knew the meaning of np but this
may be the first time you've seen a
clear
definition of it an
ap theorem is an np predicate
which is true for every x
that is a theorem
that says for every x there exists
a y such that f of x
y is true
where the bit size of y is at most some
polynomial of the bit size of x
and where f of x y is a predicate
given by a known polynomial time
algorithm that is whose running time
is bounded by some polynomial
in the bit sizes of x and y
a theorem is an np
coin p theorem
when it says that the negation
of some known np predicate
p1 equals some
other known np predicate
p2 in other words
for every x p
1 or p 2
not both
clearly an n p co np theorem is a
special kind of ep
theorem most ep theorems don't have
the not both
[Music]
the ideal way to prove an ep theorem is
by a polynomial
time algorithm which for any x finds a y
such that f of x y is true
that's not the traditional way because
of pigeon holes and
parity arguments i
do not conjecture that for any ep
theorem there is always a polynomial
time
algorithm proof
however it seems that there is one for
most ep
theorems i do conjecture
that there is a polynomial time
algorithm proof
for any np intersect cohen p
theorem including factoring
in fact the national security
administration and many
universities are desperately
trying to do that these days
known
np co-np therms are
rather rare whereas ep
theorems are pervasive
existentially polytime theorem
is in fact a formalization
of what discrete mathies often
intuitively regard as beautiful
well now here is a
small subset of ep
theorems that are
presented in
[Music]
every i think
almost everywhere anyway book
on graph theory
i i'm not going to take time now on this
talk to
[Music]
read everything that
is in the text the text of the talk
has been posted for simon's
it's available has been available and
will be available
and i hope that you take a look at
it
so here are a few
just a few of the many wonderful
ep theorems in discrete math
here's another one one by my mentor
alan goff allen hoffman
which i very much
well which i know you'll love if you
take the time to read it
it's proved by linear programming theory
or alternatively
it's proved by polynomial
time network flow methods
this presentation is in memory of alan
hoffman
who died two weeks ago at the age of 96.
he was an important mentor to me and
other people
he was the mathematical computer
scientist who had the most
mathematical influence on me he took me
kiting
he supported me at the rand common torch
workshop
in 1961 after my talk
and had breakfast where he said things
like
jack you really should study the simplex
method
here's a very important ep theorem
not normally seen to be one
the strong perfect graph theorem
i stated in an unusual way
i hope you will it's probably the most
important
page of my talk
worth your studying
because the way it's stated
as an ep theorem asks
for the obvious algorithm
that to prove that ep theorem
which actually has not yet been done
[Music]
so please read this particular page
paul seymour is central to
groups who did the strong perfect graph
there
also did for coloring of planar maps
and other fabulous achievements
excuse me for not clearly citing in this
limited exposition
is great readily known co-researchers
and excuse me for not citing a lot of
other people
that have contributed
unintentionally to this talk
let me see now do we want to oh this is
about the four
color theorem which is which i recommend
you
read we'll skip it
here is a slide
about the wonderful tate's theorem 1878
which we're going to skip for now
an n-dimensional centrifugal complex is
a finite
set of nodes or vertices
and a set of unordered n plus one
tuples of vertices called the rooms
of the complex a one-dimensional
symphysial complex
means a simple graph
the complex is called a pseudo manifold
when each wall is in two rooms
it's not quite a monopole to be a
manifold it has to be nice at every
vertex as described here
it simply has to be spherical at each
vertex
but what is an n minus one dimensional
sphere
ah that's problematic
the next so called room partition ep
therm is about a pseudo manifold
s
with a given subset say
r0 of rooms which
partitions the set
of vertices
actually whether or not
a pseudo-manifold has
such an r0 is probably np-complete
but in this theorem
we're given the manifold
and we're given a
set of rooms which partition the
vertices
that subset of rooms is the rooms is
called
r0 you can think of
a triangulated two-dimensional sphere or
the plane
since that special case is
quite interesting enough
curiously there is a four
color uh curiously
where the four color theorem is proved
by a polynomial time
algorithm which is too complicated
except for a computer
this roon partition ep theorem is proved
by an
algorithm which is simple enough to
teach in kindergarten
but we suspect there is no
polynomial time algorithm
for
the theorem for proving the theorem
here it is for
any triangulated surface in fact for
any n-dimensional pseudo-manifold
and for any subset
r zero of the rooms of s which
partition the vertices of s
there exists another different
subset call it our star of the roms
which partitions the vertices of s
in fact r star star
is equal to the given
r zero and so the number of room
partitions
is even
here is written at
the algorithm what i'm going to do
now and i hope you'll read it what i'm
going to do
now is show you a movie of an instance
of it
the algorithm for finding another room
partition
this for in other words for proving this
theorem
is not polynomial time
there's a sequence of inputs where the
number of
rooms grows by a fixed amount
while the number of steps doubles
in fact we suspect that there is no
polynomial time
algorithm for pairing the room
partitions but maybe there is
let's look at this movie
of an example here
is a
triangulated sphere if you regard all
the outside area
as one of the triangles
and here is a given
room partitioning
this can be our r0
the blue rooms there
we're going to see how to get a brother
[Music]
room partition and
just to remember that it
it's different from this one
the brother room partition is going to
include
the
the bottom room here
rather than this one let's look at the
algorithm
ah first we have to choose some
node we'll call it w it doesn't matter
what node v we choose some node
and that's what determines the pairing
of all the room partitions
of the manifold
there we make that switch
we replace the room containing the node
w
by the other
room containing the wall
the same wall not
including w now that triangle
that room bumps in
to another room of our room partition
so now instead of having a set of rooms
that include w
we have some unique node
that's in two of our rooms what do we do
well of course we do this
but again we run into this problem
of having a near room partitioning
so again
we run in to having a
near room partitioning again
oh look again my goodness
again my goodness
oh again oh what is happening here
ah again
you see over and over we get this
situation
of there being a unique point that's in
two of our current set of rooms
so it's almost but not quite a room
partitioning
is this ever going to stop well of
course it has to stop
because it it's clear that the algorithm
never repeats
and the only way it can stop
is by a
different room partition which you see
there
so that's it now look
let's see how in fact this algorithm
looks
exponential take our manifold
and juggle it a bit
we got a new room there and what we're
going to do is
insert insert in this room
a copy of the whole thing
[Music]
insert in that room that
okay you see we inserted that
in there and now
we have
this starting room partition
but we'll see that applying the
algorithm
[Music]
when we increase the number of rooms by
a constant
amount the number of steps in the
algorithm
doubles and so the algorithm
is not polynomial time
let's see how this goes it's going to go
on for a long time here you see
there it is our new room partition
okay there's a similar non-polynomial
time
algorithm for pairing the perfect
matchings in an even degree
graph
a non-polynomial time algorithm for
pairing them which proves all right that
there's an
even number of perfect matchings in any
even degree graph
but the algorithm
is not really suitable for finding
another
perfect matching there is
an entirely different algorithm
which is polynomial time for given a
perfect matching
find another one
might there be a polynomial time
algorithm which given
a room partition r0 the vertices of a
triangulated sphere
finds another room partition
r star but maybe r
star star is not r0 and so
we don't get a pairing
maybe there is a polynomial time
algorithm that does that
even though even there could be that
even though there could be
no polynomial time algorithm preparing
might there be a polynomial time
algorithm for
finding a nash equilibrium
even if it is not by a polynomial
time pairing something like that lemke
has an algorithm
a search problem is called
[Music]
ppa complete
if any problem of
pairing any problem of pairing
can be reduced in poly time
to this search problem
a number of search problems which pair
say steamboats of some kind
have been shown to be ppa complete
and it is reasonable to suspect from
this
that there is no polynomial time
algorithm for pairing the steamboats
i conjecture that
room partition pairing is ppa complete
in other words i suspect that
any problem
of pairing
[Music]
can be polynomially reduced
to room partitioning
however i think that even if there is no
polynomial
algorithm for finding a pairing
which always exists
there might be a polynomial time
algorithm
anyway for given a steamboat
finding another steamboat without
finding the pairing
here's a wonderful new parody theorem
i call it the danish alternating color
parity theorem
for any complete graph with
edges colored red and blue
and for any integer k
bigger than one there is an
even number of length k
color alternating paths
well for k even bjornie tough
proved it with a ridiculously easy
pairing algorithm
it's a lovely homework problem find that
pairing algorithm
other danes independently eventually
found proofs that there is an even
number of length k
color alternating paths
when k greater than one is odd
but curiously there are proofs
that of evenness
their proofs of purity are
not yet by an algorithm
which actually pairs such paths
even though of course a pairing
algorithm exists in principle
i don't know of any reductions between
room part
room partitioning the danish alternating
color
theorem and other known
parity theorems except of course
for a few of the known
ppa complete problems
finally
as a part of
a sat symposium
we had the ep thermo
called large sat is
easy
it's nicely proved by a counting
argument
given a conjunctive normal form
formula say f
let 1 over 2 to the k
be the weight of a clause with k
literals
for any clause of the formula
where k is the number of its literals
give that clause the weight 1 over
2 to the k all right
for moderately large k
ah i should say here let the weight
of the formula be the sum of the weights
of its clauses
now clearly for a moderately large
k
you're going to need
awfully many clauses
in order for the weight of the formula
to be at least one
well the large sat
is easy theorem says
for any c and f formula f
either there is a valuation of its
variables which satisfies
f or else the weight of
f is at least one i was thinking i'd
describe a polynomial time algorithm
which finds a satisfying valuation
whenever f
has weight less than one but what the
heck
instead i'll award a gold painted trophy
to anyone who sends me an enjoyable
exposition of ep therms
which includes their personally designed
polytime algorithm for
given a c and f formula with weight
less than one finding
a satisfying valuation of its variables
well thank you for reading this
and we can talk about it
anytime you wish by my
email that's right there
[Music]
that's all folks
hello we're back um
so thank you for the the very nice
lecture
jack and i love the am the animation so
that was great too
um we have a chance for some oh let's
it's hard to clap but let me
clap for the whole group
something that's missing from our zoom
presentations
and now we have a question and
discussion session um
we have you know plenty of time for some
good some good discussions so i hope
people will uh post some questions or
just speak up whichever you prefer
and uh let me find my chat window here
hello
do you hear me do you hear me
yes we hear you my question is will
russell speak
in a few minutes yes russell will be
speaking in a few minutes
okay so we'll have some time for
questions with you first and then
russell will be talking next
but a few minutes means 20 minutes so we
actually have quite a bit of time
yeah we we might start yeah we have
plenty of time i want to start russell
in no more than 20 minutes but uh
but we could uh so um but yes but we
have uh
we have plenty of time for some
discussion here so let me see there's
nothing
in the chat window
yet i might actually ask a question on
my own to kick things off
um you mentioned at the very beginning
about np
intersect co-np theorems and that
they're
they're rare so i wonder if you had
anything to
say about your favorite candidates for
np-intercept co-and p theorems
you mentioned factoring do you have any
other ideas in mind for
np-intersect co-np theorems that we
should be working on or thinking about
factoring is the most important one the
linear programming duality theorem
is an important one which
was finally approved
by a polynomial time algorithm some
20 years or so after i conjectured it
uh all right so
then there the combinatorial ones
are are a few on metroids that i just
happened to discover while i was looking
for a
np cohen penis to solve the traveling
salesman problem
my idea in 1961 was
well now if i'm going to get a if i'm
going to get a good algorithm
for finding a hamiltonian cycle
in a graph
i i of course i need to do that in order
if i'm going to do the traveling
salesman
uh if i if i'm going to get an
algorithm for that well well
it'd be a good idea to start with
a good characterization that is an np
coinp
theorem so i spent years
between 61 and
65 the reason i put off
publishing anything until 1965
was i just had
confidence that in those three or four
years
i'd find an np co-np
uh theorem
that would enable me
to tackle
the traveling southern problem well
i didn't find it so in 1965
i conjectured that b is not equal to np
uh but in the meantime
i had found a number of other
uh np co and p theorems and
by polynomial time algorithms
thanks for the question
okay let's see there's a question from
albert do you want to uh speak it or
should i read it for you albert
oh i can ask it if you can hear me well
i can ask it
so first of all thank you very much for
the inspiring talk it was very
interesting and nice so the question is
whether you're aware of some existential
theorem that has the flavor of
factorization like every integer has a
unique factorization into primes
but that is mostly combinatorial and not
number theoretical
uh i don't really see a distinction
between algebraic and
algebra and common torque they're
they're they're both discrete math
and i don't know where the division
would be
but uh the interesting
the the interesting aspect of your
question
an important question you're
asking is that indeed there is
an np coinp
which if a
polynomial time algorithm
is found for it
will provide a polynomial time
algorithm for factoring
it's uh that theorem is
not on the top of my head at the moment
uh russell can probably think of it most
enough probably maybe you can but anyway
anyway
it's a it's a very simple np co-np
term that is true
and
and
hey is everybody still there yes
hey we're here we're having troubles
hitting you though
yeah yeah we're having some troubles
hearing you jack
did what i say makes sense yeah it's
just
so hey sam is that primality itself
is in np-intersect co and p so we could
formulate
factorization as a uh
as a um
as a challenge of the kind that you said
so there's a witness that something is
composite
because there there's a
[Music]
there's you know first we could just say
you run the
deterministic primality testing
algorithm
that's already if it says no then then
that
number is composite so such a
factorization must exist
and the challenge is to find it but even
before that
von pratt had succinct witnesses of
primality
um so you could say given such a witness
can you find the factorization
is that thank you russell
it just occur are you hearing me
i am i hope i hope uh it just occurred
to me uh one other
npco and p
problem that is still
asking for a
polynomial time
method and that's a game
that's a game that and
conan wrote about
i am not prepared i'm not good at things
off the top of my head if i had been
good at that i'd have been a newspaper
reporter instead of a mathy
uh but but
look up what in conan did
on a really really nifty game
some years ago that is a beautiful
uh unsolved
np co and p
predicate and solve with regard to
a polynomial time algorithm
okay so i seem to recall
that there was progress made on this
problem
uh and i think it is now there isn't a
polynomial time algorithm but i believe
there's a quasi-polynomial time
algorithm
great will you please send me the
whatever's been done on that
i haven't looked at it for a few years
okay i will try to find it yeah if you
can make available if you can make that
available
was it originally anyway i first learned
about it from ann
khan and uh maybe 20 years ago
if if you can
if this seminar can find that
it would uh it'd be interesting to me
and probably
many other people
yeah i believe and ask anne to come talk
about the seminar
so another that's not quite np-intercept
co-np but
uh graph isomorphism i i guess it's in
uh
np intersect randomized comp is that
still the best oh yeah
oh yeah so that also has a
quasi-polynomial time algorithm now
but is there any related question like
graph isomorphism that's
in np-intersect comp
and not known to bnp tell me you tell me
sam
okay i'll ask the audience i don't know
about it okay
i think like closely related are group
isomorphism questions
but you'd have to find so i know uh josh
groucho
groucho has looked at that
i'm not sure what the current state is
okay well it's really really great if if
if
other people in this seminar would
help me and help
everybody in getting together
these np
and these np comp theorems
that are asking for
polynomial time algorithms as i say i've
made
i made my career on
finding a few such things related to
metroids and matchings and graphs
and stuff like that
but in fact as i said in my talk they're
not that many
calling p np going to be theorems around
well sam you've done some work on
showing that that such theorems
have oh i guess there's a difference
between
uh ep and np intersect comp so
you're looking at like right of
different theorems
yeah yeah i mean there are theorems that
says that certain types of proofs that
things are in np-intersect co and p
automatically give a polynomial time
algorithm but the
type of theorems that jack showed in his
talk like the
exponentially long chase through
triangulations
or choosing choosing rooms as he called
it those theorems aren't
amenable to these types to prove so at
least not directly it's an open question
uh that they're in atom p intercept
commp because these are
feasible proofs inside bound and
arithmetic uh that to carry those out it
has to be a polynomial time procedure
underneath the proof so but
this is about the general question is
much harder just the sheer existence of
being an mp intersect co-mp
by the way the purpose of my
talk was to encourage
us to begin
systematizing
looking for algorithms for
ep theorems
uh i've shown one
where
a polynomial time algorithm probably
does not exist
uh could we find lots
more of those and could we find
lots more polynomial time algorithms
for all the other scans of ep
theorems around
that was the point of my talk wasn't it
yeah
good so i guess the point of an ep
theorem is you could also translate it
into
satisfiable instances of of of
satisfiability
right yeah
yeah that's good yeah good
okay but hey hey hey wait a minute you
guys
at the end i give a
satisfiability ep theorem
i posted that on a news group about a
hundred years ago
but i've never heard what became of that
and yet here you're arranging a
symposium with all
all this stuff on on on on
solving satisfiability uh
well what uh what about what about my
large sat
is is is easy
wouldn't there be a variable that that
setting it preserves
largeness say again would there be a
very so say you're given a large sat
formula is there always a literal that
you can set
that when you restrict by that literal
preserves largeness
yes yes there is
that's the idea you in fact you can take
any one of your literals
and you set it to true and you said it
the false
i mean that's the idea you you got this
formula
that where its weight is less than one
you can take any one of the variables
set it to true and simplify set it to
false
and simplify one of the two
is going to be a formula that
still has uh
a weight less than one
got it that's basically the algorithm
hey is anybody there we're here yes
we're here um
did it make sense what i said yes
we have a comment in the chat window
that maybe does the calculations
you know p plus one plus u less than one
implies either
yes i'm left out
i've left out uh what you do to simplify
but that's
that's that's standard uh
platinum stuff
yes very good we have a proof in the
chat window as well as
those russell's comment very good um any
any remaining questions we've still got
a few more minutes
um
well i guess that's everything for now
uh if you really what if you really want
to waste some more time i can read some
more of the talk
we do need to move to russell but uh i
wanted to give people a chance to
if they have another question to ask it
right now um
so let's i'll thank jack again and
everyone uh
joining in i hope and uh we'll take
about a
two or three minute break and start
promptly on the
hour or depending on what time zone that
you're in half hour in about three
minutes
uh with a talk by russell and uh
jack i hope you'll stay around if you
want to there might be some more
discussions i'm
gonna get curiosity of what russell has
to say
about sat because he always says nifty
things
he's the smartest guy i know
okay very good thank you again
so we'll take it it's now still still a
three minute break and we'll start again
promptly at the hour
thank you hey i